he's gone Rovers on fire no save me but
with the only ones who matter and
everything they've taken from us we're
going to check back and with strange
words are make foolish people do the
great victory I saw in the flames all of
it was a lie
every one of us is poor and polished yet
we can overthrow an empire you're in the
great game now and the great game is
terrifying order your man to step aside
or there will be violence I choose
violence
No No I've never been much of a fighter
apologies for what you're about to see
hey youtubers is Charlie everybody
proceed to freak out in an orderly
fashion they dropped the Game of Thrones
trailer a week before we expected it so
just careful for spoilers from
everything that's happened on the show
so far can we all agree that Cersei has
the best line in the trailer I choose
violence whole lot of new footage whole
lot of dead Jon Snow so I will console
you with a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's for the season 5 DVD which is
dropping next week so anyway on a new
footage here we go if you guys don't
recognize the song that they edited into
this it's wicked game Game of Thrones
will sometimes take old songs and do
modern takes on it but we open up with
this downward shot on Jon Snow from the
end of season 5 usually episode 1 of
each new season of Game of Thrones picks
up in the aftermath of the previous
season's finale
so we're rolling right into Jon Snow
bleeding out at Castle black Jamie
writing it from Dorne with merciless
body trying to convince what looks like
a catatonic Cersei that life's still
worth living we're gonna take it all
back I'm so happy that Jamie's pissed
not happy that it still seems like he
and Cersei are still a thing but I think
it's just because so many of their
family have died their relationship in
the books is a little more strained that
extra little bit where you says more
makes you wonder if he's going to go a
little bit crazy this season we're gonna
take it all back and more her to tell if
Cersei is screaming internally here or
if she's getting ready to explode that's
the beauty of Cersei it's really hard to
tell what her mood is until she opens
her mouth this is probably when she sees
Jaime's ship ride up she's just really
happy to see him but then he has to tell
her all about Myrcella hey Jaime guess
what happened last season they threw me
in prison shaved my head what do you
been up to well our daughter was
poisoned by one of our mortal enemies on
all not a bad vacation this could be the
onion night on top of the wall gorgeous
morning has fallen Lord Stannis
he's probably reeling after what
Melisandre told him about Stannis is
fall Ramsay probably not sure what to do
when he finds out that Sansa is missing
has to tell his father she was the way
that Roose Bolton was going to secure
their hold on the north that was the
whole point of getting him married to
Sansa it's really hard to tell who this
hotdog the Bolton's are cooking is it
could be someone from Stannis's army
left over at the end of season five or
it could be from later in season six
most of the footage here looks like it's
from the first couple of episodes but
every once in a while they will include
stuff in the Train
from later in the series doesn't this
just remind you of the thins cooking
Ali's family during season 4 all of it
was a lie I like the way it transitions
from the flames to Melisandre talking
about how her cause has been a lie this
whole time she really needs some
dramatic act of the red God to reignite
her faith use as many fire puns as you
want Jorah and Daario looking for
Daenerys it as predicted they find the
ring that Daenerys dropped on the ground
walking captive with Khal Jacko's
khalasar look at this sea of people but
I'm wondering if they're at vias Dothrak
right now which is the capital of the
Dothraki we can band together an
overthrow an empire he's talking about
King's Landing in Westeros you can see
how Daenerys is going to have a similar
storyline where she tries to inspire
these people to come together
welcome back Greyjoy's maybe this is the
kings moon Sansa and looking none the
worse for wear in furs so she might
still be in the north as we seen these
other pictures here she could be at the
last hearth with the umbers she could be
at white Harbor we know they're doing
small Jon number so I'm gonna guess for
now that she's up at the last hearth in
this picture
Tyrion seems like he's left in charge of
Daenerys his small Council he has miss
and I grey worm and Varys of course when
he's talking about great game he could
be talking to miss and I he could be
talking to Sir Jorah he's just talking
about the great game of Thrones I like
that wicked game great game Game of
Thrones
drogon back in action can I wait to see
the faith militant versus Robert strong
zombie Mountain will crush you all until
we get to clicking Bowl and don't we all
choose violence that's probably what
would have happened if they had not
dropped the trail in the next week or
two this is probably the most queen like
moment I've ever seen from Cersei most
of her power moves in the past have been
when she's just being super [ __ ] or
witty or cutting you down with some turn
of phrase now it's like the faith
militant has woken the dragon these
people are wearing stark leather armor
please oh please let this be connected
to the Targaryen armor later in the
trailer and be part of the tower oh joy
flashback that would make this Ned Stark
but it's really hard to tell these are
the mutinous nights watch brothers
trying to get to Jon Snow's body they're
probably trying to burn it because even
if they're skeptical about White Walkers
people being raised as whites
they don't want to take their chances I
know it seems like Tommen is marching
against Cersei but he's not going to go
against his mother what
I'm really wondering for his character
is if he starts to assert his own will
because in the books he's much much
younger so he might start rearing his
head to northern army going to be a
giant battle we saw in the behind the
scenes gonna be so much fun it's really
hard to make out the banner on this ship
but I am going to cross my fingers and
say you're on Greyjoy Arya taking some
licks learning to survive while she's
blind Littlefinger finally gets his ass
back into the north cannot wait to see
what Sansa does to him what she meets
him again how dare you make me marry
that monster Margaery still in the black
cells this could be a wildling chasing
down one of the Nights Watch brothers
this is part of that really large Bolton
army you can see the flayed man banners
flapping in the wind sons of the harpy
still terrorizing myrin going to be a
big problem for Tyrion and Varys so this
man here it's really hard to see the
crest on his chest he's wearing the same
type of helmet as the Bolton army so
unless this is a Sansa loyalist I'm
gonna guess that they catch up to Sansa
and Theon this actually looks like
you're on being baptised by the Damned
fair what is dead may never die twincest
not quite done yet Brienne versus more
Bolton's maybe she actually does catch
up to Sansan Theon in the image we saw
of Sansa with ferzaan earlier in the
trailer it seemed like she had escaped a
certain amount of danger so maybe
Brienne saves them from being recaptured
by the Bolton's Melisandre looking into
the flames fingers crossed for a
Melisandre vision she has POV chapters
in the books so I'm hoping that we at
least get to see her vision this is
footage from the house of black and
white that we saw in earlier teasers
just gonna continue to be a really big
location in the show in season six
please oh please Melisandre do not try
to have sex with Jon Snow's dead body I
don't think that shadow babies worked
that way at least they're able to get
him inside but I do like the idea that
the rest of the Nights Watch tries to
chop down the door so they can burn his
body I'm gonna guess that this park
[ __ ] is actually from Braavos and it
just flows from the idea that Arya is
trying to become more of a badass even
though she's lost the use of her sight
this could be Bolton's versus umbers I
see some skins there could be wildlings
the Bolton's will have to address the
wildlings at some point because they're
settling in the gift and that's within
the domain of Winterfell this is Yara
Greyjoy getting it on do not know who
she is making out with oh dear Jesus
euron greyjoy rainy bridge at the sea
stone chair Bremen
Melisandre's leeches something big from
the books is going to happen here please
use spoiler tags if you want to comment
about it because it's probably straight
out of the books yeah that definitely
looks like a dragon so here's the theory
what if this is from the Tower of joy
flashback that would be another way to
see Targaryen xin armor guarding the
Tower of joy guarding Liana start for
Rhaegar Targaryen
tormund Giantsbane in the wildlings
versus the Bolton's Margaery looking
like she's trying to confess to the high
Sparrow blind arya please show her some
mercy all the mercy puns you can think
of these soldiers are actually from
Highgarden and it looks like they're
trying to take Margaery back by force
remember the Queen of thorns did
threaten the high Sparrow but he was
like if you cut our grain off we are the
many you were the few so in addition to
Cersei vs the faith there is also
Tyrells versus the faith at least from
the queen of thorns it'll be interesting
to see if Margaery drinks the kool-aid
but based on what the actress has said
I'm guessing not Sansa on the run in
what looks like the moments right after
she and reek jumped off the battlements
of Winterfell
Dothraki charging wildlings charging
Shorthair bran
having a vision maybe in the lands of
always winter turns around in oh hey
what's up bro it's the night's king this
is the night's king but it's a different
actor it looks like a different actor
than the night's king from season 5
regular white Walker hanging out in the
background in anchoring the relay is The
Onion Knight grabbing long claw looking
like he's going to fend off or kill all
of the Nights Watch that are trying to
charge in and take Jon Snow's body he's
so polite sorry for what you're about to
see poor ghost here just sitting watch
over Jon Snow's body makes me wonder if
the Onion Knight is actually speaking to
him I know a lot of people want to
believe that Jon Snow Ward
into ghosts body but usually if you're
not a really powerful word you have to
be line-of-sight and we didn't see ghost
anywhere when Jon Snow is being killed
so let me know what you guys favorite
moment from this and what's going to
happen is I'll totally do a Q&A for this
in another day or two just give people
time to watch it a couple times new
trailers always make me so happy
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my top 10
foreshadowing moments on Game of Thrones
and you can click here to learn all
about the Tower of joy if you guys don't
know about that thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you